in Austria all adults will be vaccinated
from February at least that's the
government's plan it'll be the first
European country to introduce a general
vaccine mandate
many other nations in the EU are also
considering at least a partial mandate
affecting medical and nursing staff they
join the likes of Italy which has
compelled those in nursing professions
to get the Jabs in Spring
Italy is also the home to the so-called
green pass requirement on public
transport at work or in a bar Italians
must be ready to identify themselves as
vaccinated recovered or tested since
this rule has been in place many more
Italians have got the Jab
I'm Daniel winter and this is your
covid-19 special
Italy the UK and now Germany all
requiring those in Health Professions to
get vaccinated proponents say it's the
only way to ensure patients are
protected critics argue it's an
infringement on an individual's rights
lays the ground for a general vaccine
mandate meanwhile there's concern about
staff shortages if vaccine skeptic care
workers respond by quitting the
profession DW's Christina kufner reports
Matthias busman has worked as a
geriatric nurse for 12 years
supports the German government's vaccine
mandate for health care workers to keep
the risk of infection as low as possible
for everyone here
you feel safer knowing for certain that
all of your colleagues all the people
who you work with are vaccinated
it's nice not having any uncertainty on
that front uh
though the exact number isn't known
there are still many in Germany's
Healthcare sector who aren't vaccinated
that's why Andrea Yeager is open to
mandates
but she says they shouldn't be limited
to health care workers
I'd like to see the government move
swiftly to introduce a national vaccine
mandate instead of starting with the
sectors that are already in the
Limelight and Under Pressure I don't
like the message this sends or the
pressure this puts on nurses it's like
telling some people you must get
vaccinated while essentially letting
everyone else take their sweet time
since they're not as likely to drive up
infections
a nationwide mandate is under debate but
if passed it wouldn't go into effect
until next year to protect the
especially vulnerable a partial vaccine
mandate is being implemented for all
nursing home staff a move welcomed by
many in the sector
you can't just single out any one group
or industry because there's no way of
knowing if they're the ones responsible
there are so many people involved in
running a nursing home from housekeeping
to the janitor from care attendance to
those who work in administration and
often enter patients rooms
but some worry that the combination of
covid-19 Staff shortages and vaccine
requirements are placing too big a
burden on workers already stretched
their limits
those who are still left to shoulder
this undue burden are being put under
even more pressure and I worry that this
could be the last straw that they'll say
I can't do this anymore I won't do this
anymore and quit
nurse Matthias busman thinks there's no
way around a national vaccine mandate in
order for Germany to reach its Target
vaccinate anyone and everyone as fast as
humanly possible
mandatory vaccines for targeted groups
are on the way in Germany the German
Parliament the bundestag passed a bill
making jobs compulsory for health care
workers
Walter ricciardi is a professor of
hygiene and public health and he joins
us now Walter thank you very much for
speaking with us so is mandatory
vaccination a good idea after all many
countries already have a shortage of
critical workers such as in health care
so it could cause problems in that area
it depends on the situation of course in
times of the pandemic with an incredibly
contagious respiratory virus can be a
measure if you don't have an appropriate
coverage and you are overwhelmed by the
request to have access to hospitals and
health care and of course in this
situation you can take this the tough
decision the extreme decision to
introduce mandatory vaccination of
course in ordinary time that wouldn't be
the case but these are not ordinary
times
yes extraordinary times you say call for
Extraordinary Measures and critics say
though that measures like these are an
infringement on human rights and so even
if everyone got vaccinated there'd still
be restrictions and infections every
time a new variant came along what's
your reply to those critics
my reply is that we leave a pandemic
which is an incredible danger to all
humanity and if we don't vaccinate all
the Mankind in the in a shorter term we
will leave this experience for years and
of course the health will suffer first
but economy will suffer second so to get
out from this situation we have to
vaccinate all over the world not only in
richest countries and that's the only
reply that I have so when you introduce
this kind of measures you must have in
mind that this is an incredible danger
for all humankind
and we've seen in many countries such as
Austria recently which has introduced to
vaccine mandate massive protests against
these measures what's the response been
in Italy
now we have had not mandatory but we
have managed to to persuade people
actually with their incredible success
because we have almost 90 percent of the
vaccinable population that up to now is
vaccinated of course there is a
resistance but the noisy minority is not
more than two three percent so have been
some noisy protest but they are
decreasing now
okay but they would argue
um that at the moment everyone can get
the vaccine vaccine if they want it's
free
um it's quite widely available in Europe
um and so those people who don't it's
their personal responsibility if they're
putting themselves at risk
um do you agree with that point and if
not at what point do we simply have to
accept an increased risk in society
the problem is that again we are dealing
with an incredibly contagious
respiratory value so if you go into a
place where you have infected people
particularly with this Omicron variant
you are you get infected so it's not
ordinary times where you can walk around
and maybe have a vaccination for some
disease that is not transmitted by a
respiratory apparatus so you have to
have in mind that these are incredibly
challenging times and then again as
special decisions you have to be taken
and how do you think that Omicron is
changing how we think about our reaction
to the pandemic because it seems like
it's an entire other level of
um the viruses spread just as we were
getting used to the Delta variant
the Delta variant has already changed
the game but the Omicron is going to
disrupt even more because it's
incredibly quick to be infected and is
incredibly quick to be contagious so we
have to understand that not only the
vaccine which he persists as a
fundamental prerequisite for fighting
this battle it's okay but it's not
enough so we have to pair vaccination
with our Behavior so Universal masking
ventilation hygiene so these are all the
measures that we have to adopt all
together to fight the disease
okay well we're not very happy with the
situation but that's the way it is it
seems the pandemic continues for now
Walter ricciardi thank you very much for
giving us your expert insights on that
you're welcome
now it's time for you to ask and for us
to answer here's a viewer question for
our science correspondent Derek Williams
how many ICU patients are unvaccinated
it proves surprisingly tough to find
really current hard data for this answer
especially from places like the US and
Europe where the pandemic landscape is
really in flux at the moment but there
are plenty of anecdotal reports about
who's being hospitalized for example the
comments by a well-known Oxford expert a
few weeks ago that covid-19 in the UK is
generally no longer a disease of the
vaccinated because vaccines he said tend
to limit its suffocating Affliction
um the latest government surveillance
report there says that vaccines remain
90 effective against
hospitalization at least with Delta now
this is pre-omicron other countries in
Europe have reported higher or lower
percentages of vaccinated ICU patients
but in general the data fairly closely
mirrors what's being reported by the CDC
in the U.S
its most recent calculations from 14
States at the end of October say that
unvaccinated people over the age of 18
reflected by the blue line that they
were being hospitalized at rates around
eight times higher than vaccinated
people so the green line
but breaking down covid-19 sufferers
into percentages of vaccinated and
unvaccinated patients in a country's
intensive care Wards can also distort
conclusions about How likely it is that
people from the two groups will end up
there especially when a large percentage
of the population is vaccinated to
explain let's look for instance at a
theoretical Society of a hundred people
where 90 are vaccinated and 10 aren't
four of the hundred end up in the
hospital from covid two from each group
what's reported is that 50 percent of
the patients ending up in icus are
vaccinated which is true but some Vital
Information is missing which is that
while 20 percent of the unvaccinated
people are ending up in intensive care
only a little over two percent of the
vaccinated are a very different picture
this was just a theoretical example but
the principle is being exploited to say
that vaccines don't protect you well
from severe disease and for the Delta
variant at least that's not correct
and finally as the world struggles to
Stave off covet cases in the human
population
veterinarians and Charities hope to keep
animals safe too just take Chile's Boo
and zoo in Santiago where Lions Tigers
and even orangutans received vaccines
this week the zoo injected 10 of their
most susceptible species using an
experimental formula donated by zuatis a
global Animal Health company
and that's it from the covid-19 special
thank you very much for watching
[Music]